et oui il est là il est beau il est
chaud aujourd'hui on se parle du nouveau
waimes et xs de meetic cesse de quoi
sauter du haut quand on voit pas comme
ça et c'est un smartphone qui est
intéressant parce qu'il est grand on
sent quasiment rien son doigt on peut se
connecter à d'autres appareils c'est
vachement cool le prix est un peu moins
cool on est quasiment à deux lunes roll
is extrêmement cher croise maroni qui a
priori pour l'instant ne sortira pas en
france alors on va regarder ça
tranquillement au score autour d'un café
je vous emmène à milan parce qu'on a
milan on va commencer par un petit
retour en arrière pour arriver jusqu'à
ce smartphone en valais voit bien ce
smartphone il n'y a pas que ce
smartphone il ya des montres il ya plein
de choses on est parti pour un tour près
du but mais xs 2 à milan et ça c'est
cool
[Musique]
et où est ce qu'on est on est à la
maison de huawei s'est écrit juste
derrière en fait aujourd'hui il ya un
truc c'est le premier événement européen
que nous faisons est depuis la crise
donc on va dire par les deux mondes
connectés y aura peut-être des
smartphones qui se plie je peux pas le
dire vous vous savez pas ce que vous
avez cliqué dessus moi je le sais pas
encore je vais découvrir je vous emmène
en balade aujourd'hui c'est de la
découverte un peu votre blog techno va
tout regarder c'est très cool on est à
milan et à milan on fait quoi et bien à
milan on se marre parce qu'un milan il
fait beau il fait chaud et on va
regarder ce qui se passe et vous allez
voir mon avis ça est plutôt cool
ça fait combien de temps qu'on n'a pas
fait d'événements comme ça
avec la mine de rien bah ouais
j'aurais dû prendre on entend la plage
en chine et il est fort lors à une fois
la boue droit comme ça c'est pas
vraiment fort voilà
le logement comme client qui emplit
yable
alors intéressant offrira sa poche n'est
pas prévu pour la transmission qu'il
arrive à plus tard
désactivez votre don wall premier où il
posait alors ce soir vachement cool le
seul truc à savoir à qui est vachement à
temps
comme ça il nous faut absolument une
coque de protection
vous allez soient payés
oui nous a montré que et quant à exister
la france suit adresse en matière de
coûts
simon
il est vraiment intéressant parce qu'on
vend beaucoup de lui en mai
moi des formats qui arrivent et qui
développe et celui là mais quand même
plutôt pas mal il est assez joli c'est
un écran cassé mans est une idée ou l
autre
j'ai bien commencé
[Musique]
on se pose dehors sur le parking anglais
plutôt pas mal pour un bien alors il
fait une chaleur est incroyable effet 29
degrés en plein cagnard je vous raconte
pas je rentrais bronze et ça va être
dingue je vais être prêt pour les
vacances alors on se parle un petit peu
de ce smartphone est quand même s'il va
pas arriver pourquoi c'est intéressant
d'en parler pourquoi c'est intéressant
de comprendre parce qu'en fait vous
savez même si huawei ya quelques années
a perdu les services google et à réagir
avec ses propres services avec la
galerie avec un catalogue s'étoffe de
plus en plus c'est bien et bon il faut
encore un peu de temps pour que ça
arrive mais ça continue à arriver et
pour l'instant ils n'ont pas prévu
d'emmener un smartphone pliant à priori
en europe et en france sauf que là il le
présente quand même se ruent
présentation européenne donc ça serait
pas surprenant qu'on voit arriver
courant 2000 valent deux peut-être 2023
j'en serai mais ça paraît assez logique
un smartphone qui se plie pourquoi nous
présenter un smartphone qui se plie là
aujourd'hui à milan pour ne pas le
mettre jeu c'est pas faux ça bizarre
donc non il est présenté c'est
intéressant alors ce smartphone je
trouve intéressant ne pas le format on
l'a déjà vu avec le mythique cf on a
déjà parlé par le passé et là c'est une
belle nouveauté c'est une belle mise à
jour on voit qu'on a un très grand écran
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'ils
comparent un petit peu forcément à la
concurrence et le samsung galaxy cette
folle de trois on a une diagonale qui a
un poil plus grande on a un smartphone
qui un peu plus léger qu'un iphone 13
promax avec sa coque alors ils viennent
mettre avec sa coque pour gagner les
quelques grammes de différence bon
pourquoi pas c'est assez marrant ces
histoires de mettre des petit taquet à
tout le monde et dire regardez nous
franchement on est hyper bon il est très
fin on sent quasiment pas les payeurs se
doit donc la sensation est vachement
bien et c'est vrai que l'on a vu
notamment que le au pot fine laine en
début d'année on voit que les pays on
recommence à moin lé sentiront lançant
encore plutôt pas mal avec les galaxy z
folle de 3 mais s'attend tout doucement
à disparaître c'est vachement
intéressant d'un point de vue purement
technos asmaa punk et funk et mignon et
qui est sympa on a un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz bon ben ça
on connaissait déjà un petit peu
l'histoire diagonale de 5,8 pouces alors
qu'un galaxy cette feuille de trois
faits 7,6 pouces dont on à 0,2 pour cent
plus et il fait
255 grammes à l'horizon petite addition
on prend les 2 138 g plus à peu près 20
grammes d'une coque on arrive à 2 156 g
autant dire que on est à trois grammes
près bon voilà en fait ça fait le point
ce truc là c'est à dire un iphone 13
pronax on est moins épais qu'un galaxy z
folle de 3 il fait 6
mm le jeune paul ii iii ici on fait 5 4
mm plus fin ça c'est cool un autre qui
est intéressant aussi c'est qu'ils nous
annoncent un smartphone qui est
extrêmement costaud extrêmement robuste
avec ils ont marqué pendant la
conférence de l'aerospace brave titanium
qui est 1,6 fois plus résistant que la
génération précédente avec fibres de
glace saurais pas vous dire l'idée en
fait c'est que si vous le poser sur une
table il n'y a pas s'abîmer va pas très
gai ils ont en priori déjà fait la démo
j'en ai parlé avec un départ sonne côté
opérateurs avec qui on a pu l'espérer
qu'il est effectivement très résistante
en tout cas il semble l'être de la
résistance aussi au niveau de leur
charnière on va voir une caméra un
grand-angle de 50 méga pixels un ultra
grand-angle de 13 mégapixels et on a un
téléobjectif x 3 il ne donne pas là si
c'est un 8 mégapixels 8 mégapixels ou ça
ne paraît pas énorme c'est bon c'est pas
là-dessus façon qu'ils vont chercher
beaucoup de technologies beaucoup
d'innovations c'est pas forcément cette
gamme là mais ça me paraît pas dingue
alors on a un ultra grand angle au
niveau de la caméra de sel fils on est
sur un 10,7 mégapixels ok pourquoi pas
et on a un focus laser bon ok pourquoi
pas et ce qui est assez marrant plus
haut niveau des fonctionnalités c'est
que lorsque votre smartphone il est pris
les plier la personne que vous prenez en
photo se voit sous forme d'un moniteur à
leurs trucs et marange que vous prenez
quelqu'un photo n swell peut faire le
gouffre très bon si elle est belle mais
vous lorsque vous prendre en photo avec
le smartphone est plié bienvenue
phocéenne qui vont les cas pour venir
vous voir donc l'idéal est pas mal alors
ici la batterie c'est du quatre mille
six cent millions fehrer de la recharge
rapide 66 watts lui tombe sur eux et mu
12 et avec tout le savoir faire de
huawei à l'intérieur et on a à
l'intérieur
8 + 500 12 giga de stockage et de tarifs
annoncées c'est en
1999 euros qui tout en étant parfois
automatique cesse de retrouver un
pêcheur on assurerait quasiment généraux
d'être un petit peu cher si on est en
cuisine on sait assez ancien
alors regardez ce que nous sommes ouais
c'est la ouate gt3 pro ce qu'on voit
c'est très très très très lifestyle je
me rappelle plus de la référence de
celui là je le montre ces packs
céramique en blanc comme ça je trouve
super élégant on va la retrouver
également regardé comme cela c'est tout
mignon tucano il ya plein de finitions
différentes ces montres recette restera
on verra ça plus tard parce que en
existe de référence qui arrive en france
ils ont présenté vachement produit cette
écoute 5 qui vont ils en france et c'est
là qu'il veut partir avec laissera
apprennent ça avec ma [ __ ] et c'est la
ouate gt3 pro qu'on regardera contestera
parce qu'elle est super
et c'est là où h phie 2 et les
gouvernements
écoutent ça va très très bien et toi
quand je vois que toujours alors à quand
un coup à contre jour voilà qu'hier et
là oh là là le beau gosse tu en penses
quoi de ce mythique cesse de paix coûte
moi je trouve que c'est un certain
plutôt intéressant
il beaucoup évolué depuis le premier est
un des trucs que j'aime toujours c'est
le fait qu'on ne voit pas la pliure sur
ce smartphone
tablettes à écran pliable donc c'est un
truc que je trouve très sympa maintenant
c'est toujours le même problème c'est
que ces esprits vers l'extérieur ont
potentiellement si on le pose sur la
table peut-être que il est rayé d'un
côté plus rapidement que de l'autre j'ai
peur soit ça ça me fait toujours un peu
peur mais d'après huawei on devrait pas
voir ce problème c'est cool d'avoir
avoir présumément sur la tête web et
c'était beau de préhension qu'est ce qui
t'a plu plus en contention aujourd'hui
alors dans la présentation ce que j'ai
beaucoup apprécié là où on trouvait dans
un endroit étant un grand fan des
smartphones pliable c'est quand même
meetic saison c'est sacré pour l'instant
est ce qu'ils paraissent et pas
forcément prévu en france j'espère de
tout coeur que ça va être le cas
justement parce que je suis fais
intrigué par le côté résistant au niveau
de l'écran au niveau de la charnière le
fait que ce soit beaucoup plus solide 68
pour utiliser au quotidien toi comme
j'ai dit c'est un
un smartphone pillages et enfin des
smartphones pliable gelé pas
officiellement dit sur la chaîne youtube
et c'est vrai que je suis retourné chez
apple sur l'iphone tout simplement à
cause de l'optimisation un style juste à
cause de ça et je t'avoue que les
smartphones pliable nous manquer et non
mais bon tout ça pourrait
potentiellement tout tenté ouais
regardez-moi la délégation française au
bar bravo monsieur gbagbo le foot mais
félicitations aux kiwis toutes nos
félicitations à l'essai broker pourquoi
mon petit mojito à je suis tu sais que
la délégation française à touba car toi
tu es en train de venir en l'allumant
décembre
[Musique]
en plus de ça nous ont présentés
démontrent des jolies monte et on a un
peu tous les côtés ils ont montré
énormément le montre combien de
référence 6 une ombre je vous avais déjà
parlé de l'oeuvre de son tik tok ou un
style abril je sais plus et une optique
à prendre votre tension qui vient se
gonfler en fait on ne tirera comme ça
vous a laissé partir comme ça en 30
secondes vous avez votre tension
artérielle et tout cas c'est intéressant
donc ils continuent à aller dans la
santé continuent dans l'innovation même
une montre a ajouté l'agencé la watch
gt3 gros qui permet de plonger jusqu'à
150 m en plongée alors sur le sport l'a
déjà énormément d'usagé une encore un
qui veut appliquer un smartphone sans
lauren il se réoriente chose mais même
là sur la plongée oui ça repousse un peu
les limites et c'est super intéressant
parce qu'une montre aujourd'hui elle
fait croire c'est effectivement un
instant pour le sport c'est un assistant
pour vous rendez vous pour passer un
coup de fil pour recevoir des messages
pour mettre une horloge pour rappeler
qui vous voulez mais qui continuent à
aller plus loin et améliorer le système
donc ça c'est cool avec en plus leurs
applications de santé qui va beaucoup
plus loin ils vont beaucoup plus haut
niveau de l'applicatif de même un
système que vous pouvez prendre un
abonnement reprise arrivera en france
est pour l'instant uniquement en
allemagne et en italie et en fait à tout
génial avec ça c'est qu'en fait ça vient
vous faites deux guides de nutrition ça
vous dit ok voilà qui vont vous mangez
bien pour faire du sport ça vous coach
aussi pour le sport donc c'est l'espèce
de solutions de santé de bien-être au
niveau de l'alimentation haut niveau du
sport c'est un tout en oeuvre pour ça
c'est assez coûte je vais bien sûr avec
mail à la personne il rentrait bien
c'est le soleil s'il fait très chaud
aujourd'hui à milan fait extrêmement
chaud viala donc leila tu me donnes de
produits qu'on va tester ça c'est cool
watch gc ca là je testerai voile exprime
donc c'est celle là est le modèle élite
on se rate est bientôt par l mois le
prix de sa tâche mais bien et très bien
mais on a
ah ouais
c'est cool ça c'est du monde contestera
très bientôt sur youtube merci beaucoup
c'est madame noël madame cadeaux box
d'auxonne en parlera très bientôt
solitude et voyez c'est super
intéressant parce qu'en fait moi ou et
continue à innover on le voit au niveau
du spa tron pour le veau au niveau
applicatif
de la chanteuse votre plein jour ça
c'est intéressant on regardera toutes
ces questions deux mondes connectés un
peu plus tard je sais pas si smartphone
arrivera il arrivera le smartphone ou
pas on sait pas où on sépare toile tu me
le dirait pas si tu savais tout et c'est
vraiment pas bon de toute façon on ne
sait pas ce qu'est ce qui est sûr c'est
que les sites de montres elsa arrivant
c'était les séquences assez cool donc on
fait quoi et bien on se donne rendez
vous très bientôt pour continuer à
parler tech bien évidemment tc dénoncé
lundi à tenter ce titre est une chose
mais beaucoup de choses du côté de chez
huawei n'est pas que par les tec de
façon un peu globale donc c'est cool
vous fait croire cliquez sur le bouton
rouge si les rouches et vous n'êtes pas
abonné vous actionnez la cloche pour
notifier dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrivera et une des prochaines vidéos
face à ça mais ça c'est cool voilà vous
embrasse et moi je continue de faire le
fait à milan fallu à boire un coup
[Musique]
m